cholet nathalie et journaliste basé à
rome salut bonjour alors dit no de
quelle façon se passe le déconfinement
en italie alors c'était une échéance
très attendue après deux mois de
confinement strict dans le pays
en réalité je dirais qu'il s'agit moins
d'un des confinement de la population
que d'une reprise des activités
productives qui concerne pour l'heure
environ 4 millions d'italiens et qui se
poursuivra de manière graduelle ces
prochaines semaines mais pandémie elle
est en recul constant depuis deux
semaines le nombre de nouvelles
contaminations sur le territoire et
chaque jour inférieurs à 2000 et depuis
27 avril ce qui est très encourageant
néanmoins comme vous le disiez le
gouvernement craint beaucoup le fameux
risque de deuxième vague du virus une
peur qui est très très répandue dans
toute l'europe et donc à cet effet le
gouvernement met tout en oeuvre je
dirais pour limiter les occasions de
rassemblements ce qui a pour effet de
rendre cette phase numéro 2 assez
délicate est restreinte mais au final
très concrètement qu'est ce qui change
dans le quotidien des italiens et bien
compter d'aujourd'hui vous le disiez les
italiens pour rendre visite à des
membres de leur famille ou à leurs
conjoints mais pas à des amis c'est
encore proscrit en revanche la pratique
du sport à l'extérieur l'accès au parc
seront à nouveau autorisées à titre
individuel avec un ou avec un
accompagnateur pour les mineurs les
restaurants ne peuvent pas encore
accueillir de clients bien que les
ventes à emporter puisse reprendre les
choses se font vraiment très lentement
le port du masque est bien sûr toujours
obligatoire dans tous les lieux publics
clos notamment les transports en commun
les bureaux ce qui est normal il reste
cependant interdit donc de se déplacer
d'une région à l'autre de voir ses amis
comme comme je le disais la reprise des
célébrations religieuses a quant à elle
été reportée au mois de juin
malgré les protestations des élèves
italiens ce qui a été relativement
vecteur de tension dans le pays
alors concernant pour vous répondre
l'état d'esprit des italiens je leur ai
compris
il s'agit d'une reprise relativement à
demi teinte en demi teinte les réalités
sont quand même je dirais relativement
disparates selon les régions il n'ya pas
d'uniformité
mais quoi qu'il en soit l'euphorie n'est
pas n'est pas au rendez vous on peut le
dire
la situation demeure très incertaine les
italiens ont peur pour leur avenir
ils ont déjà fait beaucoup de sacrifices
ils ont déjà fourni énormément d'efforts
et à ce propos je souligne aura une
opposition citoyenne qui est qui a
émergé à ces derniers jours ces deux
dernières semaines
en réaction aux mesures gouvernementales
jugées trop rigide par une partie de la
population qui perd patience qu'il veut
se remettre vraiment à vivre pleinement
et elle s'est notamment rassemblés
derrière le hashtag tholoniat mots
libérez redevenons libre sur les réseaux
sociaux
elle réclame dès à présent une plus
grande marge de manoeuvre au quotidien
bien sûr dans le respect des mesures de
précaution donc voila un petit peu un
tour d'horizon de la situation ici merci
beaucoup solène pour toutes ces
précisions en direct de rome solène
tadié je rappelle que vous êtes
correspondante europe au national
catholic register